Professor,
thank you for laying out this framework, I think it's really helpful. The issue that I had with it though,
it seems there's maybe an element of
ethnicity
demographics and socio-economics that might be missing and
this sort of goes to your, your comment on the malcontent of religious people.
You think about that in terms of a socio-economic standpoint, it might be
that lower-income communities around the world might be the sort of more malcontent of religion and I'd, I'd like your, your comment on that.
And then if you think about sort of the smorgasbord, going back to the smorgasbord
religiosity, it seems like
only the luxury of the Western world be able to
pick and choose their religion, right. I mean, that's, that's sort of an element that seems to be missing here. So, I guess, I'd, I'd just like your, your comment on sort of where we can fit
each of these
strands in terms of socio-economics
and, and
and, and the ethnicity part.
I think it terms of socio-econmics, I, I think I gestured toward it when I said that
a smorgasbord religiosity in the West and in a certain layer
in, in the, in, in the rest of the, well
that's, that's too,
it's not quite accurate, but, but, but certainly you have to have a certain
you have to be of certain socioeconomic status, simply to make your point,
in order to
engage in, in this kind of
creation, self-creation of
religious identity for, for yourself, certain sense of power, certain sense of agency and so forth.
In terms of lower level and, and
socio-economic lower level in terms of embrace of religion
it's, it's true and you would expect it, but, you know, the book that two editors
of Economist have written
by the title *God Is Back*, which is worth, worth reading, flipping through
begins with a, a reading group of, of highly educated,
kind of bible-reading group of highly-educated folks in Shanghai
and there, in many other
situations you have
highly educated
young professionals
who are embracing religion. Look at New York is a good example.
If you look at somebody like Tim Keller,
one of the New York preachers, right, if you go to his church,
average education is master's degree, right,
and, and average age, thirty-five,
right.
And it's a, it's a, it's a rather influential and huge church and you have, it's replicated in many of the
metropoli.
Is that plural of metropolis? Yes it is.
Thank you. London,
certainly there are churches of this, of this sort and I think it's true also of
other religions.
Sure, but, but I would that
those communities aren't, are they, they're not feeling let out from globalization, are they?
Well, what, what, what, what
they might be feeling is disorientation. Okay.
They may, they may not feeling, they may not be feeling a sense of, of
material
well being not being,
not being fully satisfied with their material,
material, conditions,
but they may be feeling that
they don't
have sufficient
means to organize the meaning of their lives, sufficient strength
to pursue the life as they want to pursue
the life, what they find valuable
and maybe finding in faith
resources of that sort. Disorientation is an interesting word because you have, this goes to the ethnicity question that I had. If you look at the Europe paradigm, you have a pretty homogenous populations in Europe historically.
And, whereas, you know, you go to
the United States and it's a, there a lot of
pluralistic society, therefore,
maybe people are more religious because they have
an other to
identify themselves against or define themselves against.
And so,
there's got to be that element in this.
But, but, but remember the Europeans as homogenous as they may be
were quite
gladly kill one another over religion over a long period, a very long historical period.
And there was a kind of implicit peace treaty that went along with the nation-state and democratization. I was going
to say that the Pew Charitable Trust research on, bears on the question of malcontent or
people, people who feel left out of globalization being more religious. There is a, a
middle strength correlation
between passing through the development
and, and demographic
transitions and the
decline
of average percentage of religiosity. And within countries of all levels,
there is a, an at least
mild correlation between lower economic
status and greater, greater
expressed commitment to religion.
Pew had there, you know, they're producing huge number of data sets on this stuff. And I,
I think much of what, what you're saying
is independent of the very fine-grained empirics. And the last point you're, you're,
you're observation about higher-income people having a sense of disorientation to which faith may be a response. I think that's very important point. And there are,
there is a sense, many people, I think, have a sense of emptiness and the relativism that goes with great affluence and the smorgasbordization of belief.